[Music]
one year after Harry and Megan's
fairytale wedding we're breaking down
all the royal details you might not
remember that shake who Kenny Mason the
19 year old cellist who played three
pieces during the interlude what's even
cooler is how his role in the wedding
came to be Perry and Megan saw you
perform and then Megan called you
personally yeah I mean the cool was a
very weird thing and something I never
really expected but of course I was so
honored to accept an invitation to be
here and say oh hey man it's the future
dust Duchess of Sussex you want to come
party at the wedding or how did that go
down something something like that as
for another person making worked with
directly dress designer clear wait color
I think she got the factor I was British
designer and working in a house such as
your aren't you Claire actually helped
make and incorporate a few meaningful
details into her wedding gown and veil I
came up with the idea of maybe
representing each of the countries of 53
countries of the Commonwealth through
their flora and fauna and we both love
the story of that and it also meant that
every single one of those countries also
journeyed up the aisle with heritable as
a really
I knew that it would be a fun surprise
as well for my now husband who didn't
know and he was really over the moon to
find out that I would make this choice
for our day together mmm also had this
surprise literally up her dress
somewhere in here there's a piece of did
you see it the piece of blue fabric that
stitched inside no is my something blue
it's my it's fabric from the dress today
we're on our first date let me just tell
you about that royal wedding it was
transformative wedding guests Oprah
Winfrey nearly made her own fashion faux
pas she had a little bit of a wedding
emergency yesterday she sent me a
picture of the dress and she was
planning to wear it and it was gonna be
a cream color but it came out and it was
bright bright white Gayle King outed her
bestie during CBS's coverage of the
Royal Wedding she also revealed that
designer Stella McCartney saved the day
with lady OHS new pink number and while
we're talking wedding guests we might as
well address
Harry's x-factor there's quite a bit of
speculation about whether ex-girlfriends
are going to be invited to this wedding
turns out not one but two of the Royals
ex-girlfriends Cressida bonus and
Chelsea TV showed up in support the key
thing was that while they loved Harry
they weren't prepared to make the
sacrifices that Meghan has been prepared
to make but our favorite details from
the day are all the ways the newlyweds
paid homage to Harry's late mom from the
forget-me-nots and Meghan's bouquet to
the white garden roses that frame the
entrance of st. George's Chapel
Diana's favorite flowers were a part of
the Sussex couple's big day the little
diamonds are the side from my mother's
jewelry collection to make sure that
she's with us and this and this crazy
journey together and Harry didn't just
honor his mother with Meghan's
engagement ring he also gifted her this
aquamarine stunner from Diana's
collection which the Duchess flashed on
their way to the evening reception in
this James Bond as a Jaguar featuring a
license plate
the couple's wedding date
[Music]